all right i want to talk about what i
guess we're calling the alt left
on the topic of ukraine and russia i got
a question during a live stream recently
which was basically how did i
and a streamer named hassan [ __ ]
end up with such different opinions of
the russian invasion of ukraine now i
don't have the answer to that specific
question but i want to more generally
address that there is a contingent of
people who claim to be on the left and
that includes folks like glenn greenwald
matt tybee and tulsi gabbard and others
who have a very different perspective on
ukraine russia
from what i would call kind of the
mainline progressive left of which i am
a part now some of you will say david
your entire premise is flawed those
people aren't really on the left i grant
you
there's a real question as to whether
these people are actually on the left i
mean they're they're extremely
reactionary in much of what they say but
let's put that aside for now because
they're ostensibly on the left they sort
of claim to be and are considered by
many to be on the left let's call it the
alt left and you decide whether they are
on the left or are not and for our
purposes we'll be open to the idea that
they are on the left also i think it's
important to mention
some some are like why aren't you just
talking about tankies the so-called
revolutionary left this is a different
group the alt left like tulsi is not
what would pejoratively be described as
a tanki
she's something else and so that's why
we're looking for a different name and
we're calling it the alt-left i believe
there is often
one real story
and
sometimes terms like bias alternative
facts and narrative
are used to create doubt about whether
you've been misled or sold a fake story
and that there's a true real story that
you're not getting
and there's the usual suspects that are
blamed now sometimes there really are
competing narratives with elements of
truth and we have to be
very very involved in sort of
ascertaining what the truth is on russia
i believe there is one story
and that that story can be detailed and
contain nuance and that's fine vladimir
putin's decision to invade ukraine is
the principal aggression in this
scenario putin has had territorial
ambitions for reasons of ego economics
and geopolitics for decades he hasn't
made those territorial ambitions a
secret he
is obsessed with ukraine for reasons we
outlined on the monday bonus show
including this sort of vague nostalgia
for the ussr as well as resource and
economy and geography related reasons
he's now acting on them period russia
invaded ukraine russia isn't respecting
ukraine's border sovereignty and putin
is now pushing into kiev with the
bombings that started overnight applied
anywhere else
no one would accept the idea that
listen it's legitimate to recognize the
separatists in another country as
independent and then send in tanks to
protect them and then start bombing kiev
and it's not an invasion we wouldn't
accept that in almost any other scenario
in addition
okay
in addition
the situation is more complicated
because it is true
that russia might in a real way in a
genuine way
see nato's willingness to defend ukraine
and nato nato's eastward expansion as a
sign of aggression i'm not denying that
russia could very well see it that way
it doesn't change
that russia invaded ukraine
is shelling all over the country sending
troops in through belarus crimea etc and
not respecting the simple border
sovereignty of ukraine
that um they are supposed to respect
great
but the alt-left doesn't agree with that
now i'm going to do my best to
accurately represent different
perspectives from the alt left but they
include for example that the entire
government intelligence and media
apparatus is lying about what happened
this is a very common theme from the alt
left and again the alt-left has hammers
and so everything looks like nails to
the alt-left you can't trust the media
generically even though the media means
a hundred different things you can't
trust intelligence because sometimes
intelligence has been wrong you can't
trust world leaders about what's going
on and this often includes more specific
counter stories like this is actually
joe biden's fault
nato is to blame as an imperialist force
that is overreached putin is just
defending his country stuff like that
they said
the threat from putin is overblown he
has no real interest in invading he
doesn't plan to it's a lie you've been
sold by the fear-mongering bloodthirsty
government intel media apparatus for
attention posturing the
military-industrial complex and clicks
but no invasion is coming
we know that was wrong
these are very clearly bogus takes not
based in evidence and we now have the
benefit of hindsight to see how wrong
they were the biden administration
did something smart
counter to what happened in 2014 with
crimea
biden came out and said for a while
our intelligence shows a buildup of
troops on the border which signals maybe
putin wants to invade
and then biden said our intelligences
that putin has made the decision to
invade
and then yesterday they said we have
intelligence that there will be a
full-scale invasion within 48 hours
it all happened it all happened and then
biden was on record saying this is the
plan
and that allows us to say hey you know
what we were getting two different
stories and one was correct and the alt
left was very very wrong
all along the biden administration was
detailing exactly what was happening in
the expected timeline and it came true
now another alt-left trope is biden
wants war
biden did this
he warned us
as part of sabre rattling to gin up
support for a war
and everybody other than the alt-left
wants that war
first of all no we don't i mean find
one clip of me saying anything even
indirectly alluding to the vague desire
for any kind of war no
we don't want war
secondly biden has said
no troops on the ground
and he's sticking to it now if he
changes his mind i'll tell you
but people like matt taebe and glenn
greenwald and tulsi have talked and
alluded to this desire for war that
biden and the media and everybody but
them have
which uh people like them are again so
like matt taibbi tweeted i have a long
record of being critical of putin this
troll fantasy that i'm pro-putin comes
from reporting correctly that russia
gate was fake and deposing u.s
intervention of ukraine that doesn't
make me pro-putin any more than opposing
the iraq war made me a saddam lover he
insists he's just against ukrainian
intervention everybody else wants it
well biden also by the definition that
we're talking about sending troops is
against intervention and is sticking to
it now of course i am the first to tell
you
we are increasingly engaged in a proxy
war along along with our allies
i just want to tell you what things are
i have no interest in hiding that from
you we're arming ukraine
uh we're sanctioning
we yeah it's increasingly a proxy war
against russia fine but the idea of this
bloodthirsty ground war that put that
biden is determined to launch no tulsi
similarly pretending you know there's
some kind of bloodlust from biden and
harris tweeting biden harris tell us we
must bear the cost to defend freedom in
ukraine but while you and your family
struggle with higher gas prices the
power elite won't suffer at all and if
the conflict goes nuclear nuclear
there they'll be safe and cushy massive
bunkers while you and your loved ones
fry no she was wrong about all of it i
mean it's harder to find
alex berenson was like the wrongest man
in the world on the pandemic
tulsi has been like the wrongest
american on russia ukraine and then
here's glenn greenwald who tweeted
whenever war emerges there is an intense
surge of nationalism in the u.s people
across the spectrum unified the media
speaks in almost lockstep so i'm sure
the polls will indicate approval for now
but i really wonder how much americans
are willing to sacrifice for ukraine
again no one's talking about that
certainly not biden certainly not
mainline progressive leftists like me it
was a lie so the alt-left is very
misguided they got a big boost in 2016.
that's when the alt-left really started
to get built up the origins of the
alt-left
are heavily based in the idea that trump
is uniquely the fault of the left there
are these folks who started saying in
2016 hillary is just as bad as trump
uh then trump won and they said it's the
fault of the left for their narrative
and their selection of people like
hillary they insisted the trump-russia
stuff was all made up and that trump's
wrongdoing wasn't important they never
blamed
the outrageous ignorant reactionary
extremist right-wingers who actually
voted for trump they blamed the left but
not those right-wingers and this has
carried them through now to their takes
on ukraine russia so that's what's going
on
they're wrong
i'm bored by them
if you want you know and i say this
because there's so many people telling
me i should have those views just go
watch those other shows read those other
people it's not what we do here
it's this just isn't an alt-left show so
rather than wasting time emailing me
telling me i should adopt glenn
greenwald and tulsi's views just go
listen you don't have to watch this show
it's optional it's a free country as so
many people like like to say
just tune me out if that's what you're
uh looking for
we'll have more coverage of this on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show
i'm really excited that uh one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty you can try the
mattress risk free for 100 nights and
they will even come pick it up at your
house if you don't love it but i know
you will all of my viewers will get up
to 200 off your order and you'll get two
super premium pillows for free when you
go to the link right underneath this
video